when you have these woke revolutions it
requires all of us at some point to say
no not going to do this
a nation has to have civic education
they have to know what the Constitution
is they have to know where the first
amendment is they have to have some idea
who the people were that died at Shiloh
what Okinawa was about
who Andrew Jackson was who Lincoln was
who Harriet Tubman was if you don't have
models of your past you're going to
forget it
we are living in a country that has no
resemblance to the visions of the
founding fathers in the first 200 years
of our history we're losing that ability
with tribal politics wokeness cancel
culture
if you lose the idea of citizenship and
if Americans don't see themselves as
unique citizens of the United States
then you don't have a country
the people who control us on the
corporate boardroom in Hollywood and
professional sports the people on Wall
Street the people in Silicon Valley they
have found a way to siphon the profits
from seven billion people on the planet
that have an iPhone or an email account
or a Google search to an area of about
80 square miles if we don't wake up the
elite who don't believe in the American
experiment will hijack our government
if we're aware of what they're doing and
aware of the perilous status of
citizenship then we become masters of
our own destiny if we don't then the
citizenship that we've known for
centuries will die
I'm Victor Davis Hanson this is a course
on American citizenship
let's begin